disait un d'abida vous vous suivait le
cortège de la manifestation est
organisée par florian philippot son
appel at il été entendu aujourd'hui
eh bien écoutez amraoui plusieurs
centaines de personnes se sont réunies
ici place joffre devant l'école
militaire afin de protester contre
l'extension de ce pas salutaire le
président des patriotes est arrivé sur
les lieux il donnera un discours à 14h30
et le cortège ensuite rejoindra les
autres mobilisations présente à paris 1
pour donner cette impression de force de
luttant contre cet ce texte qu'ils
jugent liberticide 1 pour la plupart des
manifestants à présent ici nicolas
dupont aignan elle sera également
présent le président de debout la france
l'objectif également est évidemment le
retrait pur et simple de ce projet de
loi concernant l'extension du bassin
sanitaire et malgré l'invalidation par
le conseil constitutionnel et bien d'où
les manifestants ici ne compte pas
baisser les bras et le groupe a continué
à battre le pavé à malgré cette
validation
le président les patriotes lui est plus
que jamais déterminé à présenter un plan
de bataille beaucoup plus beaucoup plus
profond afin de contrer un l'exécutif et
sa stratégie sa stratégie mise en place
pour lutter contre le coc u19
pour lui il est inadmissible de priver
de liberté le peuple français pour
pouvoir contrôler cette épidémie en tout
cas les personnes les gens commencent à
arriver au compte gouttes ici pour
entendre
florian philippon qui donnera un
discours je vous le dirai je vous le
disais à 14h30
le meeting le cortège est ensuite se
déplacera vers le conseil d'état pour
s'unir avec les autres mobilisations à
paris présente cet après midi